oh and talk about really when you first
started
getting serious about singing tell me
about that
yeah um i feel like i didn't have the
very typical
um of coming into music or
the arts like so many people do i didn't
really start
singing until i went to high school i
went to the las vegas academy of the
arts
for choir and that's kind of when i
actually started singing
like full time i remember i had this
performance in a class called vocal jazz
my freshman year
and it wasn't a class that freshmen were
supposed to be in
but i was in it because there weren't
any other available
elective classes and i was so nervous to
sing we all had to sing the same song
so i came home and i practiced here
and i went back and i was so nervous but
then when i sang it i remember everyone
jumped out of their seat and like were
applauding me and it was such a special
moment
and that's like when i knew that this is
what i wanted to do you know in your own
words really what
does singing mean to you well i think
singing has always been a part of my
life i just didn't
take it seriously really until i was in
high school
but i think it's just something that has
always come
naturally to me i think so it just i
feel like it's i'm
such a huge part of me as a person so i
think it's just
it's kind of like an extension of my
soul kind of walk me through the
decision to
get a tick-tock yeah so um it was
right when the pandemic hit i was like
okay well i'm having
i found myself having more time than i
would if i were
actually at school all day um so i was
like what can i do with my time and i
was already on tick tock
like just kind of like just scrolling
through videos looking at other people
do it i was like well
i could probably do it too and i posted
my first video it did okay
then my second video and i got like 300
likes and at the time that was like
so many like so i like ran downstairs
and told my parents and they were so
excited
so i said okay well i'm gonna just
continue to do this and see where it can
lead me
um and from there it just went up and i
kept posting
um and have gotten so many great
opportunities since then
um now having like 700 000 followers
um which is insane and i can't believe
that that many people
like want to see me all the time singing
but it's really it's really heartwarming
and touching and people always leave
the nicest comments ever um on there and
instagram as well
there's so much has happened over the
past year yeah
and how you've been able to connect with
people through tick tock in that way
yeah when i uh originally sang rise up
i sang it actually in may and i would
sing it but i wouldn't post it i would
record it and i wouldn't post it
because i wouldn't feel the connection
to the song
and the song itself has been a
soundtrack for so many movements in the
past
since it came out but i think recently
especially the black lives matter
movement
and when all of the events in june and
the protests in june
happened i re-sang the song
and kind of unconsciously was able to
connect to it more
and was able to feel the emotion and the
words of the song more and i think
with me feeling it people out there were
able to feel it as well
what is that like to be less than a year
old on tick tock
and all of a sudden having lizzo
smith wow no it's it's really really
crazy because you listen to these
artists and you
follow them for such a long time and
then for them
to look at you and then start to follow
you and it's just
insane um after the super bowl actually
i got a comment that meghan trainor put
on my tick tock
and she said oh my god i listened to it
and i just immediately knew that that
was your voice on the commercial
which to me was like insane i was like
how does megan trainer even know who i
am let alone know my voice but um
yeah it's just it's been great and just
for able to reach for people to reach
out to me and
say the things that they do is it's just
amazing so you get a call from
indeed in january of this year tell me
about the process of them reaching out
so it was actually from an ad agency in
l.a um
who is representing indeed and it was a
direct message
on instagram and she said that they were
working on this
campaign and if i would love to be a
part of it and i said of course so she
said um can i have your email
and i gave it to her and she said it was
actually going to be
for indeed and i said oh wow that's such
a huge company
i can't wait to do it and then she said
it was actually going to be for the
super bowl
and i like freaked out i said oh my gosh
for the super bowl
and then she told me that she wanted me
to sing rise up
in it and i was like okay wow this is
really really huge
and especially for their first super
bowl commercial
ever and it was such an amazing process
working with them
um we re-recorded this song just here in
the house and they were all so kind and
had such nice things to say and i keep
getting reached out by employees of
indeed as well saying
hey christian we love you on the song
and we all we're so excited to see you
and we're just happy to see what you
have to do next and it's been it's been
amazing working with them as well
was it special to be able to
sing this song but also kind of bring
some comfort and almost
inspiration to people yeah i mean it was
i think when they told me the um the
story of the commercial and like
how it was gonna feature actual indeed
users on the commercial
it was so easy to get behind um because
um
people go through things all the time
but i think through the pandemic
people have been hit really really hard
especially
when it comes to losing their jobs and
especially here in las vegas like you
see it
every single day and i think um the song
itself the lyrics of the song
are at the beginning talks about you're
broken down and tired and
at the end of the song it talks about
and will rise up
high like the waves and i think the
message of the song along with the
stories of the actual
indeed users it just tied it all
together for me and it made it so much
better
to be surrounded by your family in such
a big
moment for you just personally
what was that like that was so my family
is my everything and they are just my
biggest supporters and have always been
throughout my entire life and especially
since i began
singing they have always been there to
support me so having them all around me
to witness that moment was really really
nice and it was really huge
for all of us what is next for you do
you have
any other plans where you want them to
take you i'm hoping that
um other opportunities like this or even
bigger ones come from this and indeed it
was so great and saying that that's what
they wanted for me as well
and them using me for the commercial um
they really hope
the best for me and they were so nice
and putting me in touch with
great people and putting me out to so
many people who could help me
in the music industry as well at that
point did you ever think
it would you'd have nearly a million
followers
be in the super bowl no
to be honest i hoped for it but i never
thought that it would come and
especially this quick um
since me beginning to post and i think
it means so much to me that people
enjoy my voice enough to think that i
would even be good enough to do
a local commercial let alone the super
bowl that's broadcast to tens of
millions of people
yeah and also with tick tock
now you have been named as one of their
trailblazers for this month yes so tell
me
a bit about that opportunity and what
that comes with
yeah so i was um nominated from
other black creators on tick tock to be
named a tick tock trail blazer and
um once i was actually awarded it it was
such a rewarding feeling
again just to think that people thought
that my voice
um as a a prominent person in the black
creator tick tock community was good
enough to be considered
a trailblazer was huge for me and tiktok
they have been
also so kind to me um reaching out and
messaging me saying uh we can help you
with this this this this
on furthering your platform and it's
been great i think
all of the creators that they chose
there's 14 of us and all of them they
sho
all of them that they chose have been
fantastic and they all are so
specific and individual in their own um
uh crafts and their own pages and i
think that's what really
ties everyone together is that we're all
different but we're all the same in a
way
well also i forgot to ask you what was
the uh
reception like from your friends and
family were they kind of freaking out
yeah to keep it a secret yes so i
couldn't tell them at
all until two days before the super bowl
and then when i finally
was able to tell everyone i got just the
nicest messages from
all of my friends and all of my family
and them reposting things on their pages
and their stories
and everyone was so kind and even my
parents friends as well were reposting
and messaging them and right after the
commercial aired on the super bowl
our phones just blew up like right like
literally as soon as the commercial
ended
we all got like 30 text messages each
everyone that was there
and i think the reception of the
commercial has been so great
not only from people in the public but
also people that we know personally
alan shelton a-l-l-e-n
shelton s-h-e-l-t-o-n and i'm wendy
shelton w-e-n-d-y
s-h-e-l-t-o-n i think it's interestingly
enough
he started singing a little later in
life
and but uh as a child he did sing we we
noticed that he's saying we have one
video when he was nine years old
and he was singing that popular uh
justin bieber song baby baby and
we actually recorded that but he did
lots of other things too he played
sports he did
art he did all types of other things and
then
um but when he got into high school and
he's saying as a freshman he sang a sam
smith song in an assembly
and the crowd just roared and that was
our first uh video
and um that we saw him singing his first
solo
and the reception from the crowd was
unbelievable and so that's when i knew
this is i know this is where he's going
we had no clue about it it was a
surprise to us someone
sent it someone sent it to us and and we
were like
wait a minute is this you why
what is this going on it was just him on
stage
and the people were going crazy i'm like
what is going on here
and i was like i was thoroughly proud i
mean he's really proud as a dad but i'm
like wow
i did not know you had this in you i
knew you could sing but i didn't know
that you were
unafraid to be in front of people and
sing which is another level so that
just blew us away and so when it comes
to tick tock
you know were you guys supportive of
that from the beginning what was that
like because i feel like
last spring none of us really knew what
ting talk was
yeah you answered to me honestly i had
no idea of what tick-tock was
and initially i was like well why are
they cutting you off after one minute
and
now i'm uh one of the biggest fans and
supporters of tick-tock because it
i just think it's just a nice little
excerpt
i don't think we you know comprehend
things too long anyway but
it's a nice little excerpt and it's a
teaser you know
to what a sensational um artist
christian and so many others are so i'm
i'm a huge fan of it it has
opened so many doors for him and um
made his voice uh available to so many
people who
need uh healing you some of the comments
that they mention are
your voice is healing it's like a hug it
makes my day
i you know you i start off on a good day
when i hear your voice
so to see comments like that from
hundreds of thousands of people and then
you know some of the
celebrities that have taken the time to
endorse christian or
duet with him or make comments about his
music it as a parent that's just the
most gratifying thing
we could ever ask for yeah yeah i mean i
had no clue what to be honest i had no
clue what tick-tock was i just knew
it was one day back when the pandemic
first hit
and i had to show home well i had to
preview a home and he wanted to come in
and
he says oh dad this is a vacant home do
you mind i
i do a tick tock and i'm like
whatever that is okay so he sang in his
home with his mask and gloves on
and that video was the first video that
we thought
viral was more than 20 people and he did
like 300 we were like
what off a song you just did in a house
that i was showing and
with gloves on i mean but it and it was
from that point
and we started thinking i said you know
just keep pushing
you know keep engaging with people keep
pushing out
because whatever you did on that video
connected somewhere with someone
so just keep doing more of that and just
be frequent to be
consistent with it and he put in the
effort which i i s
i'm so proud of it is is this
consistency because
nothing is gained without work and he
has been working and pushing
his videos and doing and because he's
such a
a humble kid i mean he really has great
humility
you know and i think we you know you
we're happy that he has that because you
want to pour in your kids
what you want the world to look like so
i'm grateful for that and just his
effort of just working and understanding
that
nothing is given to you you have to push
through
and you have to work at it and to see
what it has
come to it just it blows my mind at the
same time but i know
he has done the work with tick-tock and
i'm so grateful to indeed
i'm grateful to tick-tock for him having
that vehicle
of seeing and exposing his talent we all
we know he has talent but now i feel
like a lot more people know he has
talent so we're really grateful for that
and when you guys found out about that
what was that like ah it was they found
out before me i was actually
on well i work from home but i was on a
zoom call working
and i'm just talking and trying to do
the present stuff and they're all behind
me going
oh my gosh and i'm going stop it stop it
and so when i got off the phone and and
they told me um
i just i couldn't believe it but you
guys found out before me
yeah yeah well we you know he he brought
it to me and you know
some things are so incredibly big that
you kind of
like ah i don't believe that
apprehensive
yeah but but after talking to the
the people behind the scenes the ad
agency and
don't having zoom calls i'm like okay
this is a real thing here
this is a real thing you know because
you i could i could text someone
something and you know my buddy or
something like yeah i don't believe it
but
this completely blew our mind once we
got into it
i mean it's just like oh what super bowl
you know and as it comes and it as it
builds to that day
we just couldn't really sleep much you
know it's just anxious we're just like
what is it going to look like how is it
going to sound
and yeah and uh it was just incredible
i mean we went from getting that um and
getting that great news and then you
know doing all the behind the scenes
work and then not being able to tell
anyone that was just uh
i mean i can't even it was just
gut-wrenching having to not tell anyone
and
being that excited about it and oh yeah
um and you know he
he actually shot it right upstairs in
our game room and for
him to he he's such a professional too
when it comes to that all the technology
and all the behind the scenes he's very
very good at that and they
guided him via a web
zoom link and he was able to do it and
we're just so proud of him and the one
thing that i do want to say
with christian too is in my husband
alluded to it earlier
he's just such a good human being and
we always we're we're faithful people
and we believe that
you know with the good that he does if
you keep working something
is going something good is going to
happen to you and that's
that's what we um we never knew
something this big would happen so
soon but we do believe that if you just
continue
you know to be the good human being that
you are and try to serve as an
encouragement to others that eventually
it would happen so
to see this happen at 19 years old it's
just
it warms our hearts it really does as a
parent
in that moment you know seeing
all of his hard work really come to
fruition right there and to
you know be surrounded by family and him
what was that like for you is it special
oh my gosh that's an understatement um
it was
we had obviously seen the commercial
beforehand but purposely waited
to not watch it on a bigger screen
because we wanted to have that feeling
during the super bowl
so for me even having you know watched
the commercial i don't know how many
times just to see it on the big screen
in that moment it's it was just
indescribable and
you know he was sitting right next to me
and i was watching it and just you know
lost it in the middle of the song and
just was crying uncontrollably
uncontrollably and just thinking son
look at what you've done
look at the impact that you've made in
such a short time and yeah
and um you know just keep being who you
are and i believe
more opportunities will come like that
just to see it come through
fruition it's just something i can't
describe and
yeah yeah i was torn from
trying to be excited and hug him and
videotape the the same i'm like what do
i do
do i hug and and and film the commercial
because you know my dad is sitting next
to me
he's he's no help he's crying you know
my wife is over there and i'm trying to
get it all
i'm like well wait a minute what's going
on i want to capture the moment
but i want to be in the moment so it's
you know so
it's that is it's that feeling where as
a parent you're just
it's so indescribable that you it's like
like you know when you first have them
you know oh this
is my son yeah this is gonna be and i
have so much hope for my son
and to in 19 years to see
what is is now just his future
is so bright you know because i'm
thinking how many 19 year olds actually
have had a super bowl commercial where
their voices
in in in the cost that it takes to to
produce a super bowl commercial
and it just blows my mind you know um
just to think
about all the undertaking behind that
and who
the hell came from and that's what we're
always so appreciative because we
you can't do it by yourself but people
support you
you know they see something in you and
they give you the shot
you know he took his shot and he's
knocked it out of the box that's what
is there anything else that you guys
want to add about this whole experience
what you hope
for him moving forward anything i didn't
ask about
well one of the things that i um
just would like for people to know about
christian is that
he's just so um diverse in his genres of
music
and i and you may have seen that as well
and
he uh he didn't say it but he's
oftentimes said you know he just doesn't
want to put
be put in a box right um as this type of
singer that type of singer
you know he started off mainly with r b
and pop music and um he's oftentimes
compared to both luther vandross and
sam smith but from that he said you know
i can do everything so he's classically
trained and
he um can sing the best arias
he's won um competitions for in that
arena
for the best vocalist in the state of
nevada for singing classical music
and i just love that he can do a luther
cover
and a sam smith and a lady gaga and
do and then do classical songs as well
and really put his all
into each and every one of them and
that's how he's garnered
so many different types of um of
followers because he's so well versed in
that
and in a time you know we we teach our
try to teach our kids that they can do
and be anything that they can be and
uh as a freshman he was told you know
when he was performing in front of an
adjudicator for classical music
um a freshman in high school when he
finished he said
the the gentleman said um so do you sing
pop and r b and he said yes and he's and
he told him
oh yeah i can hear that in your i can
hear that in your tones or
i'm not sure if that's the word but he
said um i can hear that in you
and then he suggested that he just stay
in that lane
and had christian stayed in that lane
you know
it may not have led to the opportunities
but he continued to push
and pursue in the classical arena and
he's excelled
there as well as in r b and jazz
and and rock he can sing um you know uh
bohemian rhapsody like
like anybody's business so that's the
part that i just want people to know
about him is
he he wants to do any and everything
that he can
uh he loves to be challenged by all
different opportunities
and as a result he's excelled in all
those different genres and he's very
modest so that's why we have to say
those things
i think what my wife is saying is that
you got to stay encouraged
even in in light of what's going on
currently
or what someone may say to you
negatively it's just
it's just know who you are as a person
and stay
within yourself and push your light out
and people will see that regardless of
who
is so covered up that they can't see
your
your superstar you know and and i thank
god and my son
took that one moment you know as a
parent you you're like i'm ready to
fight but
but he took it and he made it work for
him
and in the in the next year he won
as the best male vocalist for two years
running in the state
of nevada i don't know who has ever done
that before but he took
that and he made it work for him so he
turned it around
so i think you just have to stay
positive because you got to go through
something to get to something
and you got to keep that in your head to
know that you know if you see something
and it don't feel good it don't feel
right just know you can go around it go
over it go through it do whatever it is
stay focused on that purpose and you
will find your purpose